The Joe Rogan Experience but I think
dogs they need something man they need
exercise they need love they need
they're like a little the little version
of you in some strange way yep you know
they're a reflection of the owner do you
buy into the idea that like dogs and
their owners kind of start looking like
each other yeah people always say that I
don't think I look like Marshall he
doesn't look like me but he's the
sweetest he does when you have your
I don't know that's the original
Marshall that's a wolf
that's what's crazy that used to be a
wolf right that someone took the most
ferocious predatory beast of the forest
that operates in packs and they
communicate telepathically and they turn
that thing into this adorable loves
punch dude okay when was the last time
this connects when was the last time you
read One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest oh
it's been a long time okay
I I think I must have read it when I was
in high school and just didn't pay
attention
it's completely different from the movie
like 100 different maybe I never read it
King keezy he would he was like can you
wrote it yeah oh no way so it's so
psychedelic the book is so psychedelic
but you know like the
the idea is that the care the character
McMurphy Jack Nicholson's character and
again this is my own analysis I don't
know what the actual like literary
analysis of it is he represents an
undomesticated human and the people in
the ward are humans that couldn't
function and what he says he calls
Society the combine they couldn't
function in the combine so they're being
brought into the asylums to get like
re-domesticated just so they could
function in the combine and he
represents like an undomesticated human
who enters into like a conditioning
Center designed to melt people back down
build them back up and send them out
into the world and be good functioning
domesticated humans it's so good it's so
subversive dude it's such a brilliant
like it's so funny how different the
movie is from it like like nurse ratchet
and again because the narrator is chief
that native the big Native American dude
who's in the movie that's the narrator
of the book it's being told from his
perspective
[Music]
so you don't know like how much of what
he's reporting is real and how much is
like he's in a mental Asylum oh my God
that's amazing so good but according to
him nurse ratchet can control time she
she'll speed up time so that like a year
goes by in a day or slow down time so
that like like a second lasts like 10
years and that's how that's just one of
the many ways that there she's basically
torturing the people in the ward oh my
God constantly giving them drugs tying
them to their beds and and always this
threat this like threat is hovering
which is if you [__] up too much
if you get too angry at nurse ratchet
who is a monster essentially the way he
describes it it's the demiur just the
Antichrist then you know what happens
they're gonna [__] give you a
lobotomy didn't cut out your brain into
a zombie and you know they really did
that yeah they really did that they
really did that they really did that I
had a professor in college who used to
work at an asylum and was the weirdest
dude ever it was an awful class on like
Psychiatry and
he was kind of talking glowingly about
lobotomies and like someone asked him
like I mean what happened to the person
and he goes they became a very good
patient
oh my God totally was fine with the fact
that they were like sticking
Chopsticks and people's you know like
brains severing the brain dude with a
hammer wearing that weird outfit why are
they dressed like that no they did a lot
of those
he did it this guy this doctor is
credited with the majority of them so
are they holding this guy down while
they're doing this or is he anesthetized
I don't know I don't see anything I see
a strap I see straps and I see people
holding his arms
Jesus Christ you know how [__]
terrifying that must be to feel that Rod
going into your brain yeah knowing
they're going to turn you into a
vegetable yeah
electroshock
dude do you remember that guy that was
running for vice president who had to
admit that he went through electroshock
therapy no yes it was during
the McGovern
um Nixon campaign Eagleton
it was McGovern's campaign right
McGovern was like one of the last hopes
he was one of the last like truly
rational what you really want out of
someone that you consider a liberal
someone who's a compassionate strong
person who
people thought that you know he could
win they thought that he could win yeah
and it says not 72 over two weeks after
the 1972 Democratic Convention Eagleton
admitted the truth
of news reports that he had received
electroshock therapy for clinical
depression during the 1960s but govern
initially said he would back Eagleton
a hundred percent a thousand percent
rather anybody didn't he eventually had
to let him go and it was too late wait
that's what took him out was they that's
who took him out whoa yeah
therapy for depression just for
depression don't people say awarded if
you had depression today
today in this victimhood Society right
if you said this vice president he
suffered from clinical depression but he
sought help he would be a shining
example look at him yeah he's like us he
was clinically depressed he got over it
he's a hero yeah and then people would
be fine with it yeah back then back then
it was a giant sign of weakness
and they they would shock your brain
with I think it works whoa it doesn't
have good results I would rather not
it's like smelling salt have you watched
videos of it because it's like it's not
like they're like vaulting you the whole
time they put these rods on your head
and you like convulse for a second it's
very disturbing maybe it's like a reset
like control alt delete for your brain
maybe it's like yeah maybe it's my maybe
it's doing like something similar to
what the psychedelics are doing it's
bringing you to a near-death experience
because your body thinks it's being
electrocuted yeah maybe it releases all
of those psychedelic chemicals yeah they
think it releases when you're a
near-death experiences